Avec ce type d'activisme,
et d'investissement communautaire typique du barbier noir,
le barbier est bien sûr l'endroit idéal
pour parler d'hypertension et des autres problèmes de santé de la communauté.
D'abord, le barbier n'est pas un contexte médical,
et il n'a donc pas tout le poids psychologique négatif
qui va avec.
Quand vous êtes chez un barbier,
vous êtes dans votre territoire, et vous êtes avec des amis
qui partagent votre histoire,
votre combat et vos soucis de santé.
Ensuite, parce que le barbier est un lieu de connexion,
de loyauté et de confiance,
c'est un endroit où vous êtes plus ouvert à une conversation sur la santé
et surtout sur l'hypertension.
Après tout,
les discussions sur l'hypertension ont tous les éléments d'une bonne conversation :
le stress et l'hypertension,
l'alimentation et l'hypertension,
les relations et l'hypertension,
et oui, ce que c'est que d'être un homme noir aux USA
et l'hypertension.
Mais vous pouvez faire plus que parler d'hypertension
chez le barbier.
Vous pouvez prendre des actions concrètes.
Nous avons ici l'opportunité de nous associer aux Denny Moe du monde
et de permettre aux communautés de résoudre les inégalités de santé
qui les affectent particulièrement.
Quand le dépistage de l'hypertension s'est étendu des cliniques et hôpitaux
aux communautés dans les années 1960 et 1970,
des médecins noirs comme le Dr. Eli Saunders à Baltimore
et le Dr. Keith Ferdinand à la Nouvelle Orléans
étaient à l'avant-garde pour promouvoir la santé aux communautés
dans les quartiers noirs.
Ces pionniers ont tracé le chemin de mon voyage professionnel
avec les barbiers et la santé,
qui a commencé à Chicago en faculté de Médecine.
Le tout 1er projet de recherche sur lequel j'ai travaillé en tant qu'étudiant
était d'aider à créer des interventions médicales
qui attireraient les hommes noirs.
Nous avons créé une douzaine de groupes d'étude
avec une large proportion d'hommes noirs,
et nous avons appris d'eux
qu'être en bonne santé venait autant du fait d'être vu comme en bonne santé
que de se sentir en bonne santé,
et que se sentir bien allait avec soigner son apparence.
Ce travail a conduit au développement du Projet Fraternité,
une clinique communautaire fondée par le Dr. Eric Whitaker
qui a fourni un service de santé sur mesure pour les hommes noirs.
Une partie de ces soins sur mesure
impliquait d'avoir un barbier dans les locaux
pour récompenser les hommes qui venaient réaliser des soins
par une coupe de cheveux gratuite,
pour leur faire savoir que nous accordions autant d'importance à leur image
qu'à ce qu'ils ressentaient,
et que ce qui était important pour eux l'était aussi pour nous.
Mais alors qu'il n'y a qu'un seul Projet Fraternité,
il y a des milliers de barbiers noirs
où le croisement de la santé et des coupes de cheveux peut être développé.
L'arrêt suivant dans mon voyage était Dallas au Texas,
où j'ai appris que les barbiers n'étaient pas seulement désireux
mais aussi pleinement capables de retrousser leurs manches et de participer
pour donner les soins nécessaires pour améliorer la santé de leurs clients
et de leur communauté.
Nous nous sommes associés avec un incroyable groupe de barbiers noirs
et nous leur avons appris à prendre la tension
et à conseiller leurs clients
et les orienter vers des médecins
pour les aider à traiter l'hypertension.
Les barbiers n'étaient pas seulement volontaires,
ils étaient aussi très doués pour ça.
Sur une période de 3 ans,
les barbiers ont mesuré des milliers de tensions artérielles
amenant des centaines d'hommes noirs à être orientés vers des médecins
pour une prise en charge médicale de leur hypertension.
Ces partenariats barbier-médecin
ont entrainé une augmentation de 20% du nombre d'hommes
qui ont réussi à retrouver une tension normale
et une baisse de 3 points en moyenne
de la tension de chaque participant.
Si nous extrapolions cette baisse de 3 points
à chaque homme noir souffrant d'hypertension aux USA,
nous pourrions empêcher 800 infarctus, 500 AVC et 900 décès
liés à l'hypertension
en seulement un an.
Et notre expérience avec les barbiers a été similaire à New York,
où mon voyage m'a aujourd'hui mené.
Avec une équipe incroyable de chercheurs variés,
de travailleurs de santé et de volontaires,
nous avons pu nous associer avec plus de 200 barbiers
et d'autres personnalités de confiance de la communauté
pour atteindre plus de 7000 hommes noirs plus âgés.
Nous avons offert un dépistage de l'hypertension et des conseils
à chacun d'entre eux.
Grâce à Denny Moe
et à une myriade d'autres barbiers et de leaders de la communauté
qui partageaient la vision d'opportunité et d'autonomie
pour faire la différence dans leurs communautés,
nous n'avons pas juste été capables de réduire la tension
de nos participants,
mais aussi d'avoir un impact sur d'autres indicateurs de santé.
Que voyez-vous?
Quel est votre barbier?
Quel est pour vous cet endroit
où les gens souffrant d'un problème spécifique
peuvent trouver une solution spécifique ?
Quand vous trouverez cet endroit, saisissez l'opportunité.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)